we're genius meets possibility I'm not
driving this car it's driving me this is
absurd the future with helping the
National Science Foundation Raj Raj
Kumar and his team at carnegie mellon
have been working on a robotic SUV
called boss of course driving along like
this might make some people a little bit
nervous at first but it turns out
driving is the easy part an even bigger
challenge comes when it's time to park
the things it comes out that parking is
a very compact manure even for human
boss uses its cameras lasers computers
and actuators to find a spot and park it
even comes back on command well thank
you very much boss you know the best
thing about a valet parking service like
this no tipping required I'm Miles
O'Brien